hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that's really excited to show
you my new Sonic OC get out of there
come on come on get out of there get out
of there you trash pandas you know loyal
theorists it's been a minute since I've
gotten to talk about my favorite blue
weirdly humanoid Hedgehog oh you want me
to go fast
ugly Sonic goes
nope nope nope not that one some things
are best left forgotten forever nope I'm
talking about the other Sonic the cute
Sonic the Sonic that's one part meme one
part recycled jokes but I am not
watching snow dogs again that movie is
the worst thank you so much for hiring
Mona Lisa it means so much to me even
though honestly she is the worst
the kids watching never saw the original
stuff John ralphiel is having himself
some big brain time right there anyway
with Sonic Frontier is getting itself
some positive reviews and a new Sonic TV
show coming out this December really a
TV show you yeah is that so difficult to
believe now seemed like the perfect time
to revisit the old Blue Blur suck on
that game theory Sonic is ours now and
whether it's in Games movies Comics or
TV shows one core part of Sonic's lore
is his insatiable love of chili dogs
in fact it comes up a lot with Sonic
more than you'd think really
like a lot a lot
that's character development right guys
that's how you make a well-rounded
character you give them a quirky trait
and then you just repeat it a whole
bunch of times over and over again
that's what I think
let's roll out Music Man anyway the dude
is always eating but when you think
about it it makes sense any character
that's gotta go fast is gonna need a
constant influx of calories to keep his
body moving it's just a Trope of super
powerful characters across all media
types Goku's always eaten everything
that's put in front of him the flash is
always munching on something going so
far as to call himself a black hole of
snacks exercise requires energy
otherwise you know you're gonna be
getting hangry after leg day and if
there's one thing that Sonic doesn't do
it's Skip Leg Day don't be fooled by the
noodle knees to move the miles he's
running those licorice legs have gotta
be a mountain of muscle so today I want
to know how many chili dogs does it take
to power a Sonic the Hedgehog what
absurd number of chili-coated cheese
slathered pork sausage not sandwiches
what our favorite anthropomorphic blue
Hedgehog have to consume to run the
insane distances and speeds we see him
going in the new Sonic movies that's
right loyal theorists today is a classic
old school science episode fire up the
grills because sanic's hungry so before
we begin to imagine the small country's
worth of very unhappy pigs will be
needing to feed Mr the Hedgehog let's
actually identify what we need to know
here first we need to know how fast
songk is moving in these films using
this we can then figure out how many
calories he's burning when he's running
then we find out how many calories are
in the sorts of chili dogs that song
eats and finally with some simple math
we calculate how many of those dogs he
needs to consume to kick things off
we're gonna actually use this clip from
the beginning of Sonic the Hedgehog 2
where Sonic thwarts the robbery of an
armored truck which shows this one
specifically because it gives us a look
at both Sonic snacking on a chili dog as
well as a prolonged sequence where he's
running to summarize he's able to head
down to the street from the top of a
building and then run what looks to be
Three City Blocks to catch up with an
armored truck all in exactly nine
seconds so how fast is Sonic moving here
well there are plenty of ways to figure
this out first let's try to pinpoint
exactly where Sonic is to get an idea of
how much ground is covering thankfully
the movie makes it super easy for us
Seattle doesn't get more obvious than
that according to the urbanist dot org
Seattle city blocks are roughly 240 feet
long we're about 73.2 meters so by
running three city blocks Sonic has
covered a total distance of 720 feet or
220 meters it is worth noting that he
zigzags a bit to weave in and out of
traffic which would add a couple of
extra feet here and there but for
simplicity's sake and because it's not
going to affect our final conclusion
we're just gonna use that 720 foot
figure so simple math here rate equals
distance divided by time if Sonic ran
720 feet in 9 seconds that translates to
a speed of about 54.5 miles per hour or
87.8 kilometers per hour next up we're
gonna need Sonic's weight now the weight
of fictional characters is always a bit
tricky on these channels but fortunately
Sega has historically been very public
with this information back in 2005 Sega
of Japan released the Sonic Channel an
official website dedicated to updates
about the characters games Comics TV
shows you can download wallpapers there
are even some simple browser games mixed
in there basically this thing was a fan
Wiki before fan wikis existed and on
that old Sonic Channel website Sega
listed Sonic's canonical weight has 77
pounds or 35 kilograms done and done
right wrong it is never that easy when
you work on these channels see across
the series there are many different
versions of Sonic all with different
heights and weights the game's Sonic
Generations explicitly shows us that
just because we're always dealing with
the same character Sonic is not always
the same I can't believe there's two of
me sometimes they talk sometimes not
sometimes they're tall sometimes not the
stats on the Sonic Channel website
appear to be referring specifically to
the Sonic from the adventure games and
spin-offs so if we want to be as
accurate as possible we should aim for
data from the movie Sonic specifically
thankfully we can find the exact data we
need thanks to capitalism you see in the
lead up to the Sonic the Hedgehog 2
movie release Sonic did a press tour
where he was interviewed by the kids
YouTube channel ckn hi I'm
today we're gonna have an exclusive
interview with Sonic Eat Your Heart Out
Phil DeFranco I don't see you Landing
those guests anyway near the end of the
video Sonic drops this truth bomb I
weigh 62 pounds and it is very rude of
you to ask I didn't ask you that
question but I did thank you Sonic you
know it might be rude to ask for
someone's weight but being slightly rude
is worth it for the science so that's
about as accurate as you can possibly
get coming directly from the source's
mouth which means that we can take all
of this information and plug it into our
calorie burning calculator 62 pounds
running 720 feet in 9 seconds drum roll
please in this scene Sonic has burned
himself a whopping two calories
oh hold on what two two two two calories
and basically burned the same amount
sitting on the couch waiting for a Sonic
06 loading screen considering an average
chili cheese dog has roughly 412
calories that means that this bite that
Sonic takes right here would be more
than enough to cover his Sprint down the
street that's no good now well the
result might initially be surprising
when you actually think about what we
just calculated it makes a lot of sense
Sonic weighs 60 pounds not very heavy
and we only calculated the amount of
calories he's burning in nine seconds of
intense exercise sure he was sprinting
real hard in those nine seconds but it
was only nine seconds for the
lightweight 60-pound Hedgehog as a
result the caloric burn for Sonic is
ridiculously low here so is that it then
is the big twist here that Sonic only
needs like eight chili dogs to power all
his Antics throughout the entirety of
the film franchise absolutely not this
is a combination film Game and food
Theory all wrapped up into one can't
just leave it at that we needed a scene
where he's running faster and running
longer I mean if we go back and watch
this whole Seattle Street Scene again
it's clear that Sonic isn't running as
fast as he can this is fun for him it's
not urgent we've seen what happens when
Sonic loses control and uses more of his
power by running full speed he likely
would have shut down Seattle's power
grid with the electromagnetic pulses
he's able to generate so I went back to
pick a better moment from the movies
honestly there are a ton of different
scenes here that we could choose from to
make these sorts of calculations I mean
in Sonic the Hedgehog 2 Sonic basically
crosses an Ocean's worth of water and at
the end of Sonic the Hedgehog 1 he moves
so fast that from his perspective
bullets and missiles are basically
Frozen in midair that said getting hard
numbers from those scenes is difficult
we don't get an idea of how far Sonic is
moving out into the water or a true
sense of his speed since everything has
slowed to a crawl but there are scenes
that give us all the information we need
on a silver platter in fact in a
previous film Theory we took a look at
this scene from the first Sonic the
Hedgehog where Sonic runs 550 miles or
885 kilometers to the Pacific Ocean and
back he was able to do this in just four
seconds meaning that his speed is 275
miles per second or 442 kilometers per
second just to emphasize how fast this
is in numbers that'll probably have more
meaning to you that's an astronomical
990
000 miles per hour or
1.593 million kilometers per hour so
going back to our handy dandy online
calculator here we plug these numbers in
and with that we find that Sonic has
burned a grand total of second drum roll
please
oh apparently during this incredible
feat of strength speed and stamina Sonic
would have burned just one calorie duh
nope that definitely can't be right what
I think might be happening is that Sonic
is moving at such insane speeds and
traveling such impressive distances the
website is calculating that he's
essentially running a zero minute mile
it is literally rounding to zero and
therefore giving us that one calorie
number it's kind of like when you divide
by zero on your TI-83 and it breaks the
universe so alrighty boys and girls roll
up those sleeves because we're doing
this the hard way to manually calculate
how many calories Sonic is burning in
the scene we're gonna have to figure out
his metabolic equivalent of tasks for
his met so to understand what this is
let's first talk about metabolisms your
metabolism is a set of life-sustaining
chemical reactions that convert food
into energy usable by your body
basically it takes the chili dogs that
you're stuffing in your face and rips
the calories out to charge up yourselves
different people have different
metabolisms meaning that they burn
calories at different rates now this is
a massive oversimplification of some
really complex biology but some bodies
are really good at taking those calories
from chili dogs and burning them while
you exercise meaning that they can more
easily keep weight off While others tend
to hold down to those calories longer
meaning that it's easier for them to
gain weight and hold on to it as such
one way to manually calculate how many
calories a body Burns is to figure out
the metabolic equivalent of task one mat
is equal to one calorie burned per
kilogram of body weight per hour of
exercise now there are tons of ways to
calculate one mat as you see on the
screen before you you know what I'm just
gonna let it sit up on screen instead of
saying all that out loud there's a lot
of numbers and letters that you don't
care about so while this looks like a
super long or complex formula we
actually have everything we need to plug
in numbers to get our answer here
specifically for that last part of the
formula for this 1.162 times Watts over
kilograms we already have Sonic's weight
in kilograms since he weighs 62 pounds
that's the equivalent of 28.1 kilograms
and figuring out the wattage he
generates with the Speedy runs is really
easy the formula for this is this
gobbledygook watts equals 150 18.007
plus the quantity negative 15.8397 times
speed plus another quantity
1.15006 times speed times speed I don't
know how people figure this out but
there it is it's got a lot of numbers I
assume they're correct so plugging in
that 990 000 miles per hour or 1.593
million kilometers per hour figure we
find out that Sonic's run to the Pacific
produces 1 trillion 127 billion 158
million 124
812.01 watts of power over a trillion
Watts okay wow all right let's take this
absurd number and plug it into our
metformula shall we given us 1.162 times
these 1.127 trillion Watts all divided
by 28.1 kilograms it's not going to do
anything running this through our magic
number machine otherwise known as a
basic calculator app that tells us that
one met for Sonic in the movie is 40
billion 112 million 338
783.3 remember that's talking about how
many calories Sonic Burns per kilogram
of his body weight per hour of exercise
how are you not dead I have no
one according to Smithsonian Magazine an
average human body contains just 125 822
calories that means in a single hour of
exercise Sonic would be burning through
over 318
000 human beings worth of calories as
one heck of a pilates class but even
with those crazy insane numbers we're
not done with all the mathi calculations
yet now we can use this information to
figure out how many calories Sonic
burned during the four second run to the
Pacific Ocean and back if Sonic Burns
those 40 billion calories per one
kilogram of body weight per one hour of
exercise we first need to multiply those
calories by Sonic's 28.1 kilogram weight
getting US 1 trillion 127 billion 158
million 100
000 calories burned per hour now we can
take this number divided by 60 to get
calories burned per minute divided by 60
again to get calories burned per second
and then multiply by four which gets us
one final drum roll please I promise you
1 billion 252 million 397 888.89
calories burned in four seconds in order
to run to the Pacific Ocean and back
with this finally we can work out
exactly how many chili dogs Sonic would
need to eat to power even just four
seconds of him running again we know an
average chili cheese dog has 412
calories meaning that Sonic would need
to eat 2 million 989
016.4 you know what let's just go ahead
and round that one up to two million
nine hundred and eighty nine thousand
Seventeen chili cheese dogs because you
know we know Sonic wouldn't dare waste
food with leftovers so what were you
expecting a dirty little hedgehog eating
berries and struggling to survive well
not exactly Sonic but dang I was not
expecting almost 3 million chili dogs
for just four seconds of running on the
whole every American combined eats like
20 billion hot dogs in a year and Sonic
would need to eat that many chili dogs
if he was expecting to run for like one
eight hour work day you know what maybe
all the government agents and scientists
in these movies are right Sonic is
dangerous to our supply of Oscar Meyer
wieners don't even ask how much this
would off sheet dogs forget it do you
know how much chili dogs cost money
don't grow on trees you know but hey we
actually talk about Sonic a lot over
here on film Theory I mean he's
basically a movie character now anyway
so if you want more content this minute
you can check out our video talking
about how ugly Sonic was actually the
best Sonic or if you want something a
bit different you can check out our
video explaining why the Sonic movies
road trip is just a big old waste of our
time doesn't matter that it was good the
science don't care about your quality
and as always my friends until the next
time remember it's all just a theory a
film Theory and cut
[Music]
thank you